what do you think is the greatest uh
computer game of all time do you do you
have any time to play games anymore
have you played Diablo 4 I have not
played Diablo for I will be doing that
shortly I have to all right there's just
so much history with one two and three
you know what
World of Warcraft
and
the game is so such a great game
it's that I remember in 2005 when it
came out how it opened my mind to
ideas
it opened my mind to like
like like like this this whole world
we've created right
look at MMOs today and I think they all
have lower user bases than World of
Warcraft like Eve online's kind of cool
but but to think that like like everyone
know you know people are always like if
they're looking at the Apple headset
like what do people want in this VR
everyone knows what they want I want
Ready Player one and like that so I'm
gonna say World of Warcraft and I'm
hoping that like games can get out of
this whole Mobile gaming dopamine pump
thing and like create worlds create
worlds yeah that that and worlds that
Captivate a very large fraction of the
human population yeah and I think it'll
come back I believe but MMO like really
really pull you in games do a good job I
mean okay other like two other games
that I think are you know very
noteworthy from here Skyrim and GTA 5.
Skyrim yeah that's probably number one
for me PTA yeah what is it about GTA
GTA is really I I guess GTA is real life
I know there's prostitutes and guns and
stuff it's just real life too
yes I know but it's uh it's how I
imagine your life to be actually I wish
it was that cool yeah
yeah I guess that's you know because
they're Sims right which is also a game
I like
but it's a gamified version of life but
it also I would love a combination of
Sims and GTA
so more freedom more violence more
rawness but with also like ability to
have a career and family and this kind
of stuff what I'm really excited about
in games is like once we start getting
intelligent AIS to interact with oh yeah
right like the NPCs and games have never
been
but conversationally
oh in everywhere you didn't like you in
like every way like when you're actually
building a world and a world imbued with
intelligence oh yeah right and it's just
hard like there's just like like you
know Running World of Warcraft like
you're limited by your way you're
running on a Pentium four you know how
much intelligence camera how many flops
did you have right but now when I'm
running a game on 100 pay to flop
machine that's five people
I'm trying to make this a thing 20 pages
of compute is one person of compute I'm
trying to make that a unit 20 petaflops
is one person one person one person's up
it's like a horsepower
like what's a horsepower it's how
powerful horses what's a what's a person
of compute well no you know I got it
that's interesting uh VR also has uh I
mean in terms of creating worlds you
know what bought a quest too
I put it on and I can't believe the
first thing they show me is a bunch of
scrolling clouds and a Facebook login
screen yeah you had the ability to bring
me into a world yeah and what did you
give me a pop-up right like well I and
this is why you're not cool Mark
Zuckerberg but you could be cool just
make sure on the quest 3 you don't put
me into clouds in a Facebook login
screen bring me to a world I just tried
Quest 3 it was it was awesome but hear
that guys I agree with that
because I uh I mean the beginning um
what is it Todd Howard said this about
uh the design of the beginning of the
games he creates it's like the beginning
is so so so important
um I've recently played Zelda For the
First Time Zelda breath of the wild the
previous one and like it's very quickly
you come out of this like uh within like
10 seconds you come out of like a cave
type place and it's like this world yeah
and it like it pulls you in you forget
whatever troubles I was having whatever
like I got to play that from the
beginning I played it for like an hour
at a friend's house ah no the beginning
they got it they did it really well the
expansiveness of that space
um the the peacefulness of that place
they got this the music I mean so much
of that is creating that world and
pulling you right in I'm gonna go buy a
switch like I'm gonna go today and buy a
switch you should well the new one came
I haven't played that yet but uh Diablo
4 or something I mean there's
sentimentality also but something about
VR
really is incredible but the the new
Quest 3 is mixed reality and I got a
chance to try that so it's uh augmented
reality and for video games it's done
really really well these are passed
through our cameras cameras yeah the
apple one is that one pass-through or
cameras I don't know yeah I don't know
how real it is I don't know anything you
know coming at it
January
is it January or is it some point at
some point maybe not January maybe
that's my optimism but Apple I will buy
it I don't care if it's expensive and
does nothing I will buy it I will
support this future Endeavor you're the
meme oh yes I support competition it
seemed like Quest was like the only
people doing it and this is great that
they're like you know what and this is
another place we'll give some more
respect to Mark Zuckerberg
the two companies that have endured
through technology or apple and
Microsoft
what do they make computers and business
services
right all the meme social ads they all
come and go
but you want to endure build Hardware
yeah and then you know that does that
does a really interesting job I mean I
maybe I'm new with this but uh it's a
500 headset
uh Quest 3 and just having creatures run
around the space like our space right
here to me okay this is very like Boomer
statement but it added windows
to the place
the well I heard about the aquarium yeah
aquarium but in this case it was a
zombie game whatever it doesn't matter
but just like it it modifies the space
in a way where I can't it really feels
like a window and you can look out it's
pretty cool like I was just it's like a
zombie game they're running at me
whatever but what I was enjoying is the
fact that there's like a window and and
they're stepping on objects in this
space
that was a different kind of Escape also
because you can see the other humans so
it's integrated with the other humans
it's really and that's why it's really
interesting than ever that the AI is
running on those systems are aligned
with you oh yeah they're gonna augment
your entire world oh yeah and that those
AIS have a I mean you think about all
the dark stuff
like
like sexual stuff like if those AIS
threaten me that could be haunting
like if they like thread me in a
non-video game way oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like they'll know personal
information about me and it's like and
then you lose track of what's real
what's not like what if stuff is like
hacked there's two directions the AI
girlfriend company can take right
there's like the high brow something
like her maybe something you kind of
talk to and this is and then there's the
lowbrow version of it where I want to
set up a brothel in Times Square yeah
yeah it's not cheating if it's a robot
it's a VR experience if is there an
in-between no I won't do that one or
that one have you decided yet no I'll
figure it out let's see we'll see what
the technology goes I would love to hear
your opinions for George's uh third
company what to do uh the brothel in
Times Square or the uh the her
experience